Yesterday afternoon, I got back from just
a beautiful bike ride here in the city of
Boston, and I was not planning on doing a
livestream until our chess tournament later
at night.
But it was announced that Donald Trump called
an urgent press conference set to start at
5:00 p.m. Eastern yesterday. And this is pretty
unusual. It hadn't been on the schedule for
the entire day and it was framed as urgent
and potentially bringing some kind of big
announcement. I decided to do a livestream
because if there's something major that's
going to happen, let's see what it is and
share it with the audience. And we wondered,
maybe they're announcing a second stimulus
package. Maybe there's some kind of big announcement
related to Corona virus. What could it be?
It seems like something big is going on. So
I did a livestream. And clearly news of this
urgent press conference spread widely because
instead of having our normal six to eight
thousand viewers on YouTube, we had more than
40000 people watched the livestream concurrently
across our platforms. And it ended up being
more than an hour of Donald Trump wildly and
belligerently attacking Joe Biden in a completely
incoherent manner, followed by taking just
three questions, not really answering any
of them. And one of those three questions
came from the outrageous propaganda right
wing news outlet. Oh, okay.
And this was actually so insane and so unprecedented
that even Fox News anchor Bret Bayer had no
choice but to mention, listen, Barack Obama
did this. Barack Obama called an urgent press
conference at the White House and delivered
what was essentially a campaign speech attacking
his opponent, even if it was a poor campaign
speech. Republicans would have lost their
minds, saying it's an abuse of power. It's
an abuse of the status of the White House.
Here is Brett Baer actually being honest and
saying it.
He spoke for 52 minutes before taking a question.
Presence in the past, by tradition have stayed
away from overt campaign rhetoric from the
Rose Garden of the White House. But it is
the president's discretion. It is worth noting,
however, to be fair, that had President Obama
made this kind of speech from the Rose Garden,
Republicans on Capitol Hill would likely have
been up in arms. But this comes 112 days,
16 weeks to the day before Election Day.
Even Brett Baer realizes this was hugely outrageous.
And Republic Republicans are major hypocrites.
Now, of course, there are people talking about
the legal question, like, is this using taxpayer
money for campaigning in the sense that this
was really a campaign event where the focus
was attacking Trump's opponent. But it was
at the White House with the White House press
corps, not campaign people covering the campaign.
But as good of an argument as that might be,
I just wouldn't focus much on it because it's
going nowhere. The focus really should be
that this is a very desperate Donald Trump
that clearly nobody around him can control.
And I know that Trump has a lot of very bad
people around him whose instincts are terrible,
but it's hard to imagine that even they would
be supportive of this. It genuinely seems
like on a whim. Sometime around 4:00 p.m.
Eastern yesterday, Trump said, put together
a list for me of things I can say about Joe
Biden and let's call an urgent press conference.
And then I'm just going to go out there and
read the list. And that's how poorly it came
off. Trump was asked about the fact that his
point polling is in the toilet. And Trump
mentioned, you know, there are some Floridians
with boats who seem to like me. I'm not kidding.
That was Trump's answer to one of the few
questions he took out.
I think we have fairly good poll numbers.
They're not suppression polls. They're real
polls. You look at the intercoastal in Florida,
you look at the lakes, you see thousands of
boats with Trump signs, American signs. You've
got the Trump Pence sign all over. You look
at what's going on. You look at bikers for
miles and miles riding up highways proudly
with their signs.
Thousands of boat owners in Florida love Trump.
That's his answer when faced with polling
data and discrediting the polls by saying
they are suppression polls. Trump, wildly
after stumbling over an acronym, claims that
Joe Biden wants to end the suburbs. Take a
look.
Abolish in the suburbs. You're going to abolish
the suburbs with this inforce. Obama. Biden's
radical a f f h a c a f f h. Regulation that
threatens to strip localities of federal affordable
housing funds unless they change their zoning
laws to fit the federal government's demands.
So what you have and I've been watching this
for years in Westchester, coming from New
York. They want to low income housing built
in a neighborhood. Well, I'm ending that rule.
I'm taking it out. So had spoke with Ben Carson
the other day. We're going to be taking it
out. I've watched that whole thing go, and
now they want to make it twice as bad in the
suburbs and the suburbs. Mothers aren't. About
that, fathers aren't happy about that. They
worked hard day by a house and now they're
going to watch the housing values drop like
a rock, and that has happened.
Trump just barely able to get through the
reading, but says Joe Biden wants to end the
suburbs. Just kind of aimlessly stumbling
around here is just like a random 60 seconds
where you'll notice Donald Trump is just jumping
from topic to topic with no rhyme or reason,
making absolutely no sense. And I believe
this is the clip where you get a shot of the
press and they're just still there like statues.
They don't know what the hell is going on.
Many countries and I did this myself for the
most part, not to use Whiteway because we
think it's an unsafe security risk. It's a
big security risk. I took too many countries
out of using it. They want to do business
with us. They can't use it. Just today, I
believe that UK announced that they're not
going to be using it. That was up in the air
for a long time. But they've decided and you
look at Italy, you look at many other countries.
We withdrew from the Chinese dominated WHL
and we fully rebuilt the United States military.
The WHL World Health Organization. We were
paying close to 500 million dollars a year.
China is paying thirty nine million dollars
a year. And China had too much say. They worked
it very hard.
Which is a bad thing done by our past administrations.
But we were tough. And we're saying I was
asking, is there why are we paying so much
more than China?
Just all over the place. I mean, really, really
bizarre. Just one other clip for you here.
Here. Donald Trump claims that this is crazy.
He claims that Joe Biden is against Windows
like, no, I'm not talking about the Windows
operating system. He's not saying Joe Biden's
a Mac guy. He's saying if Joe Biden were president,
buildings wouldn't have windows heating, cooling
or lighting, mandate net zero carbon emissions
for homes, offices at all new buildings by
2030.
That basically means no windows, no nothing.
It's very hard to do. I tell people when they
want to go into some of these buildings how
your eyes, because they won't be good in five
years. And I hope you don't mind cold office
space in the winter and warm office space
in the summer because your air conditioning
is not the same as the good old days.
This is so crazy. And it reminds me of I think
at this point, I don't know if it was like
six months ago or a year ago. Remember that
rant where Donald Trump said Democrats don't
want you to have good flushing toilets likes.
It's just stuff about water pressure. And
Sang's just really, really bizarre. So what
we had here in the end is that Donald Trump
manipulated reporters to get them to go to
the White House to rant to them about Joe
Biden. And a fight was on the fence about
voting for Trump. I mean, listen, I know that
if you're in the tank for Trump, you don't
care. You probably didn't even watch this.
In fact, there's a lot of Trump is to in order
to avoid being confronted with his incompetence,
no longer even watch Trump's public facing
events. They're just voting for Trump. They
don't want to hear anything else about it.
If you were already not voting for Trump,
obviously this press conference and this ranting
is not going to convince you to vote for Donald
Trump. I'm imagining, even though I don't
really get how anyone could be undecided at
this point, if you were one of these undecided
voters, could this possibly convince you to
vote for Donald Trump? And if, again, I don't
know how anyone is undecided. I'm not sure
if there's any of these undecided voters in
my audience. But if you are one of those people,
I would love to hear your perspective on Trump
calling an urgent press conference at the
last second and then struggling to read criticisms
of Joe Biden off of his pieces of paper. It
is very, very bizarre. Before we go to a break,
I do have kind of a cool announcement. As
some of you know, I am a very bad amateur
chess player. And over the last few months,
we've engaged with our audience by occasionally
running a chess tournament. We had one last
night with 728 players. It was a great time.
Apparently, word of my amateur chess playing
has gotten around and I have been invited
by chess dot com to be one of 16 participants
in a chess tournament next month called POG
Champs to Pog champs. One was last month.
A grandmaster, Hikaru Nakamura, reached out
to me. I said I would love to do it. The chest
that. Com team reached out to me. I said I
would love to do it. So that's where we are
right now. I have been assigned excellent
professional chess player coaches to coach
me from the standpoint of being a participant
in this tournament. And I am probably going
to be doing most of the coaching sessions
over on Twitch. And the first one is tonight
at eight thirty p.m. Eastern. So this is not
going to be like the normal oh my sharpey
is collapsing. This is not going to be the
normal sort of stream. This is going to be
twitch only tonight at eight thirty. And it
will be the start of my journey in preparing
for this tournament that will be taking place
in August. So join me tonight on Twitch at
Twitch TV Slash David Pakman. I will be introducing
you to my first of two, actually, really three
different chess coaches that I'm going to
have. I'm that bad that I need multiple coaches,
sadly, but it'll be a good time.
It'll be a nice break from all the politics
tonight. So we'll take a quick break. I will
see you in just a couple of minutes.
But then hopefully tonight, as my chess hog
champs adventure begins